what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back
with invincible yes we are we are back
with our weekly video on invincible
of course it always goes on patreon a
week ahead of time and then we release
it on youtube later
but what we end up doing here is we pick
up initially a few months ago
if you guys recall when mark fought
angstrom levy when they were fighting in
that kind of alternate reality
and mark had presumably beat him to
death right he'd killed angstrom and
then just left him to die what we ended
up learning here is that instead
a kind of portal was open and langstrom
was pulled through and despite the fact
that his face was just pummeled to mush
i mean his head was just
pummeled to absolute mush he still
survived just by
sheer force of will this guy is nothing
if not
dedicated to destroying mark you cannot
look at me with a straight face and tell
me that a man who looks like that
and survives just having the desire to
kill mark is not a man of just absolute
fortitude and dedication right now his
henchmen that kind of bring him back
here are not really his henchmen per se
and we'll find out a little more about
them here in a little bit instead what
we end up doing is picking up
seemingly in the immediate aftermath of
the last video that we did which
basically kicks off on day one and this
is the invasion of all the alternate
reality marks not all but like 20
alternate reality versions of
invincible all who have been summoned
here by angstrom levy for the purpose
of destroying mark right literally just
like not only destroying him but just
breaking him down piece by piece
these guys crush through everything
and when i say everything i mean
everything right like
they're attacking every major city paris
france they're attacking the krillin and
russia right the head of the russian
government
strangely enough one of these guys meets
spawn which is weird you only see it for
a short second right you only see a four
short second for one panel but mark
fights spawn now here's the thing you
are probably not going to see this in
the in the amazon series right you're
probably not going to see that on there
because as far as i'm aware
when it comes to the to the amazon
series amazon only has the rights to
invincible a little bit of an
explanation
here for those of you guys just a quick
super simple explanation nothing super
drawn out here
image comics skybound all those
companies they are not like marvel in dc
marvel and dc they have a shared
universe marvel's x-men cross over with
the avengers who cross over with the
fantastic four
and they team up in gravy huge books and
different things like that dc comics has
the justice league and they've got the
teen titans and all that kind of stuff
and they cross over in different books
right batman superman so on and so forth
when it comes to independent publishers
they don't necessarily have that and the
reason why
is because marvel for example if you're
writing for them they have control over
the characters so you're like i want to
write the x-men i mean marvel's like
okay cool
but you can only write them within the
certain limits of as we describe them
right so you can't necessarily have
the x-men become like a space-faring
team like guardians of the galaxy
and they just stay there i mean maybe
you can if marvel gives you permission
when it comes to things like this
skybound and image and so on they're a
publishing house and that's all they do
the creative stories themselves are 100
up to the writers they can do whatever
they want with them and then they
contract with a company like skybound or
image and then all they do is just put
their comics out there to the public so
that's why you can potentially
see something like this in the comics
where you have like invincible crossing
over with spawn but you don't see it
all the time you don't see it quite
readily but because of the fact that
amazon likely only owns
the rights to invincible and they don't
own the rights to todd mcfarlane spawn
you're probably never gonna see this but
you're probably never gonna see this in
the amazon series unless todd mcfarlane
allows it to happen
but it's a cool thing here because with
all these different versions of mark
literally just
running around cutting a swath through
the entirety of the world
and attacking all these versions mark
actually ends up coming across a version
of himself now here's the funny thing
about this
at the initial indication here we don't
really get a lot in terms of their
origins
all we really get are just small little
drops and tidbits and things along those
lines but mark facing off against this
alternate version of himself it's kind
of nuts right because he sees this
version of mark it's kind of a pale
reflection of himself right
these guys are all exceedingly violent
they are in effect versions of mark that
became
villains and they've all been brought
here because they're capable of doing
villainous things now what you also have
while that's popping off you've got
mark's mom who's watching the news
you've got mark's friends who are
watching the news and they're like we
all thought it was invincible but now
there's something like 20 of them so
they all seem to be
alternate versions of invincible even
the the members like the team team
and the guardians of the globe thought
that mark was a bad guy i thought he was
the one doing all this and it's one of
those things where it's it's easy to
play off of
right because when you look at like what
what omniman did and marks the son of
omniman
is it really that hard to believe that
mark just snapped one day and then just
lost his mind and started tearing up the
whole world i mean
nobody knew that omniman was a villain
until he was right like nobody knew that
was the case it's not his own slowly
building up to it and he was committing
a series of robberies or he killed the
guardians of the globe
in front of the world he did it in
secret did it in private right and with
the exception of people like cecil or
individuals who could who could dig into
it right like detective demon that kind
of a thing there weren't really a whole
lot of people who actually knew what was
going on
but here mark's ripping it all up after
omniman did it probably within a year or
so ago and so it's kind of nuts now
you've also got kid omniman who's kind
of doing the same thing
facing off against these alternate
reality versions of mark but again we
don't get a whole lot of explanation
here but what you do switch over to
is the pentagon and the pentagon some of
these guys are able to take out one of
these alternate reality versions of mark
and then when the question when cecil
was like okay like get people on the
horn and his little robot assistant guy
asked like who did we get right he
literally turns into gary oldman he's
like
everyone that's literally what it turns
into right the guardians of the globe
the whole nine yards
every single superhero team that can be
called is
brought in to face off against all these
alternate reality versions of
invincible and that's literally where
cecil's telling him like look guys
here's the deal right
omni man was one thing he was a hoss
right this guy there's nothing we really
could have done to have stopped him and
at the end of the day if anything if we
if we did find some way to defeat him
quote unquote it would just be buying
time
with mark we kind of stand a chance
against him because he's not necessarily
on the same level as his father
20 versions of mark i don't know what to
tell you right it's just
we have to do whatever we can to stop
this as fast as we possibly can and so
you you have like some pretty
no-holds-barred stuff cecil tells them
all bets are off right like all the
limits the the restrictions don't kill
unless you have to
do whatever you have to do to take these
guys down kill them
it doesn't matter and so all these
different superheroes some of which
we've seen some of which we haven't seen
are all literally just killing these
alternate reality versions of mark
everywhere they can
and at the end of the day it doesn't
matter one of these guys right just
one mark to give you guys perspective
here just one alternate reality version
of mark was enough
to kill the entire guardians of the
globe now one of the bigger moments here
comes from rexplode as you guys know rex
is kind of a dick right like seemingly
he's selfish he only really cares about
himself but here's a funny thing
rex has it where it counts right that's
the big difference at the end of the day
when it comes down to it he's the guy
you want on your side and the way this
plays out is that where these different
versions of mark are kind of going nuts
and they're killing all you know
this version of mark is killing the
guardians of the globe the dark wing
actually steps in
and whisks one of them away to the
shadow verse to basically and then kind
of sacrifices himself in the process to
take out that version of mark but the
damage is done right i mean this guy's
been pummeling the guardians of the
globe not only that he absolutely
crushed monster girl and there's still a
mark here and that's the crazy thing
because at that point it's kind of like
okay
like let's do what we can to try to take
this guy out monster girl seems to be
completely out of commission she's not
dead
but she's totally out of commission you
end up having robot who grabs her and
manages to get her away but only at the
behest of rex rexplode rexplo is like
get out of here you know
leave this guy to me right i'll take
care of this guy and so what ends up
happening is rex blood when the
question's kind of asked like how could
you possibly beat me right like i could
just pop your head off your shoulders i
took out your entire team
i could literally kill you right now go
find the other three who flew away and
then kill them he's like you've got
absolutely nothing that you can detonate
you've got no weapons your wrist
launcher is totally drained out you have
nothing that you can do here he's like
what what are you possibly going to
charge and explode and rexload says my
skeleton
and just detonates himself and in doing
so takes out that version of mark in the
process
rexplode kills himself in order to save
like the rest of the team from just that
one
guy right now you end up having cecil
who shows up to the actual mark right
the real mark the main mark and says
like we need you here man but adam eve
has been like
seriously injured so much so that she's
in like the icu right hooked up to like
a
mask and everything sitting in the
hospital and mark's like no i'm not
going anywhere i'm staying here with
adam e right she needs me here
you have the entirety of the world
superheroes at your disposal
you can do this without me and
ultimately ceases like man i really hope
so but at the end of the day
it really isn't enough there are a lot
of these marks that have been taken out
but then you get to day
three and day three you have eight marks
left and that's it there's really
nothing else like everybody's basically
been conquered like the world has just
been completely and totally taken out
angstrom levies his whole plot his
scheme
came to fruition and so he basically
shows back up to where the rest of the
marks are and he says okay so here's the
idea right
this world in ruins this invincible's
reputation is totally destroyed
people will always hate and fear him and
that was the goal of what he was
shooting for
it's not enough to defeat invincible
that he has to kind of
make him he has to essentially ostracize
him from society he has to put him in a
place where he can never operate as a
superhero in the world again
no one will ever trust him the
government will always watch him and if
at all possible they'll
imprison him right they'll incarcerate
him whatever the case is they'll never
let him go back to the life that he had
before and he said there's only one
thing left
i want to physically deform this guy i
want to disfigure this guy
i want him to know the pain that i feel
and so he tells all the other marks find
him
and bring him to me and they're like no
no we're not gonna do that
they literally say no and the reason why
is because the extent of the bargain
that was made between angstrom levy and
these alternate reality versions of mark
is that these versions here the ones
that had like killed their mom right or
the ones who had sided with omniman
or even the ones who had killed omniman
and taken his place
like these different versions of mark
that are here the deal that was made
between them and angstrom levy was
once they basically laid waste to this
world left this place in shambles that
he would help them expand their empires
into other dimensions so seemingly
they've all conquered their worlds right
they've all conquered earth whether in
the name of the vulture mind empire or
in their own name they've conquered all
their earths maybe even the universe
itself
and they're looking to expand out expand
their sphere of influence into other
realities and so
denying this is like no no like we're
just gonna like we'll just leave right
like
send us back and allow us to achieve our
goal or we're gonna kill you and so
ultimately he ends up sending them into
other dimensions now here's the thing
when they all get moved into this
this alternate reality they're all in
the same place right like they're
they're all locked away in the same
alternate reality which is a terrible
decision because now they're all pissed
off at them right so it's not enough to
put them in the same place to where they
could presumably get out now you're
gonna have them all coming after you
following that you end up having the
actual mark who leaves and comes
directly at angstrom levy right
and this guy is coming at him with a
vengeance like before
it was oh my god i can't believe i
killed him now there's a desire to
right now there is a desire among mark
killed this guy right not only mark but
his younger brother and seemingly
everybody else to take this guy out
do him in right just just kill this guy
initially his younger brother is like
look at what he did around look look at
what he did to the world like
kill him right look at what he did to
everything like he's like he's
like this guy right here right this is
an example of what happens when you stop
yourself
from killing someone and look at what he
did right like if this guy
was a was a person who could have been
redeemed he would have been redeemed but
you gave him an opportunity to live you
gave him a choice either go back to
being having some semblance of a regular
life and stop being a villain or
go back to being a villain right do your
own your own criminal thing he's like
you gave him an option here
men like that cannot be allowed to live
criminals cannot be allowed to live if
given the choice between being a good
guy or being a bad guy
they will always be a bad guy why
because it's what they know
stop being a milk suck right stop being
weak at the knees if you'd killed him
none of this would have happened in the
first place and that's a legitimate
argument right that's a credible
argument the proof is in the pudding
this all happened
because mark allowed him to live the
world has
basically been torn to shambles millions
and millions
of people have died because of a poor
decision on behalf of mark
and that's the aspect of being a
superhero that we don't like to talk
about there comes a time when those
folks just gotta die
and for angstrom levy it was a long time
ago but because of mark's poor decision
making he
basically he set the stage and he
effectively allowed angstrom levy to do
everything that he's done here right and
so it's one of those things where mark's
like you know what you're right
like you're absolutely right like he
literally tells his brother you're 100
right i'm
killing this guy right now anxious levy
ends up opening a portal and teleporting
away back to his base of operations of
course
mark grabs his arm his arm gets cut off
in the process and then in turn when he
shows up to his henchmen he's like i
need you guys to get me back to normal
you know like like we need his blood
you guys have to help me like we got to
go take out mark and the response they
make is
no promises were made angstrom levy you
gave us assurances we had a deal and you
failed you do not get a second chance
you do not give us orders
you work for us now and so then you
switch to day four
what's left of the world the world in
complete and total
shambles here and mark overlooking all
of it just has
well you know what guys you know what
guys you know what people
i think this is a good place to end it a
lot of you guys are just like no
a lot of you guys are pissed
cliffhangers with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you guys next week
peace